I only believe in one type of real
estate right now I'm thinking about
writing a check for 100 million dollars
and paying off a hundred million dollars
worth of debt so you might know Ben Mala
as being a 500 million dollar man who
owns a ton of real estate but today he
is losing 500 000 a month well now I got
no protection and now I'm paying 6
million a year he's a very successful
real estate investor who grew up in the
slums of Rockaway New York and today
we're getting an inside look into
exactly what's going on in the housing
market exactly what he's buying and his
entire rags to Rich's story on this
episode of make sure to subscribe and
hit the like button and comment because
it helps us out tremendously but before
we get onto the podcast I do want to say
that we spend a lot of time talking
about the importance of taking on proper
debt and how crucial it is to have the
capital that your business needs that
brings us to today's sponsor of fund and
grow who offers a simple and hassle-free
alternative to traditional financing
fund and grow understands how to help
small businesses get the funding they
need even in today's economy like
getting a bank loan today could be a
nightmare you see guys there's tons of
red tape and restrictions that seem to
just exist for the sake of being
annoying like your mustache right okay
you know with fun didn't grow I could
use that money to create a razor company
that you could then use to shave your
mustache with their 12-month membership
you can secure up to 250 000 of credit
at zero percent interest that is of
course without giving up any equity in
your company but don't just take our
word for it fund and grow already has
over 4 000 4.9 star reviews and that's
because thousands of entrepreneurs are
seeing genuine results from that fast
and simple funding and it's a special
offer for our listeners fund and grows
prepared a business funding masterclass
that will uncover the five steps to
securing up to 250 000 in business
credit and plus Graham as an exclusive
offer you'll receive 500 off of their
services so if you want to start
expanding your business visit fund and
grow today using the link Down Below in
the description and let them help you
secure the funding your business needs
thank you so much and now let's get to
the episode this is the coffee table
it's got real coffee in it
wow all right welcome to the iced coffee
hour benefit I really appreciate you
coming to Vegas for spring break spring
break baby why don't you take your kids
Miami right San Diego Santa Barbara I
feel like there's better places than
Vegas for that
the weather you're crappy the weather is
crappy outside though
it was freezing I froze my ass off and
then it started raining on top of that
yesterday I went to the mall Museum I
wasn't impressed no I knew more about
more [__] than the museum had there how
much do you know about the mob too much
but I grew up around that crap you know
my uncle was in it you know people
Google
you got all his money from uh drugs it
wasn't me that was back in uh you know I
was like 12 years old and yeah anyway uh
you know when you grew up in New York
you grew up around all that [__] every
you name every type of criminal activity
I've seen it and grew up around it
you know I'm looking at one
now when you're 12 though how did you
understand what the mob was did you or
you just like grew up around here you
know your kids in school you go to
friends good school with kids and the
parents and the family are all mobbed up
and you know it's it's really a very uh
ugly life it really is you said your
uncle's in the ear he was in his whole
life pretty much what was his like
ranking in the model what was he I think
his name was Benny the Jew and he would
be like the money guy you know he needed
money to borrow money loan shark and
gambling he didn't move a lot of drugs
too I know that I've seen newspaper
articles
and he's probably spent half his life in
the State Penitentiary or fed
Penitentiary or whatever I didn't visit
him so I'd see him when he got out once
in a while you know but I stayed away
from that yeah I mean you know it wasn't
I always knew that crime wasn't the Life
For Me Yeah plus I'm not a violent
person you know good German
you know all that [__] about hurting
people and it's just you know it's it's
not
it's not human is it is it close to how
it is portrayed in the movies like you
usually see it where they're going to
work in real life it's worse in real
life it's worse I mean because you never
know when somebody is gonna come after
you or you know there's no honor among
Steve's or Crooks and murderers and all
that I mean it's just all about money
you ever have any close calls or hear
about anything crazy to happen I mean
um you know I was around a lot of crap
that went on I was too young luckily I
got a New York when I was 17 and I
joined the army
so um you know I did get in a little
trouble when I was young so luckily uh
back then it would take you
in the Army if you didn't have like a
violent criminal record and I was not a
violent person but you know I hung out
with the wrong crowd and you do what you
had to do to survive I grew up in the
slums and really lousy poor family and
um you know so I went to court one day
um and the judge actually recognized me
and remembered me from previous meetings
that we've had in court and he I never
forget today you know I'm in court I was
about
I just turned 17 and I got in trouble
and
um so I had to bailiff you know what a
bailiff is God works in a court takes
your way to jail so I had to bailiff on
my right and had the recruiter on my
left I set it up that day where I came
to court with the recruiter to prove to
the judge I'm going to the Army if he
permits me you know gives me lets me off
so you stand in front of the judge and
the judge goes okay big shot what are
you gonna do because he already knows
I'm able to do recruiter and everything
excuse me I swear to God I saluted to
judge and I said can we go now and that
was it and that saved my life because
otherwise I'd be dead I'd be dead or run
away in jail negotiating since 17.
probably a lot earlier than that
I ran away from her home when I was 12
years old I was a big 12 year old why'd
you do that not as big as him but you
know why'd you run away
I came from a very dysfunctional family
my mother was very abusive
all right and she had mental illness and
she was basically a raven Luna she could
beat the [__] out of you for no reason
uh my father he was pretty much the
opposite he'd encouraged you to drink he
didn't smoke and he didn't stand up to
my mother like he should have
you should have put your [__] in her
garage in place but anyway they got
divorced and I was young blah blah blah
and or um there's always fighting going
on and anyway I got stuck with her
and uh you know eventually when I was 12
years old I was hanging I wouldn't go
home I'd stay in the streets or go by
French houses and you know got involved
with doing the Mischief in the
neighborhood it was pretty rough growing
up in New York you know in Far Rockaway
in the projects where it was really sad
so um what's your question
uh why'd you run away want to run away
because it was a horrible place to live
it was a little [__] box house and a
really dangerous neighborhood and uh my
mother was nuts and she didn't care when
you ran away
she didn't care when I was there
she's probably happy I ran away and you
know so you know I did what I had to do
I lived on you know friends in the
streets I sleep on the train you know
maybe we had very long rides on the
train in New York
you can get on the train Far Rockaway
take it all the way to uptown Manhattan
that'd be like a two or three hour ride
so you can get three hours of sleep
going that way and going back but Ryan
you don't get robbed
um you know but um did no adult see you
and just say like Hey we're your parents
where are you going no one question you
know you gotta understand I'm 57 now you
know I'm talking about I was born in 65.
you talk about 1977. sorry in 1977
throughout the 80s New York was a sewer
all right that's why you know Trump was
able to do all that crap in the 80s
because everything was garbage it was
down it was crime ridden I mean the
Mafia the the drugs the crime everyday
crime you can imagine
consume New York it was a cesspool so
you know I mean nobody ever questioned
my age when I was young it was just
something nobody cared you know and how
did you fund your life when you were 12.
I mean you know hustling you know
basically back then we had what we call
a um
a tray bag you know what a tray bag is
back then things are cheaper you could
go with three dollars trading stream by
the way you could take three dollars you
know the right house to go do you knock
at the door
and you know when you put the deadbolt
lock in the door
it's a hole it's empty
there's no locking it there might be
other locks but there's an empty hole
there you put your three dollars in a
hole and this little bag comes out with
three dollars worth of marijuana
but
back in those days you take the bag
papers didn't cost much
and you clean it up you roll them up you
get five joints
and you can sell those joints for a
dollar a piece so now my three dollars
just turned into five dollars
the Jamaicans had to hold corn on that
market and they were pretty generous
so then you take the five dollars and
you go back and you get a nickel bag you
know nickel bag is I'm assuming yes
so basically you take the five and
really because I would be such a pain in
the ass to them they would actually
threaten me to get away from the door
I keep looking in the bag and giving it
back no I need a bigger bag I need no
it's got too many seeds in it no it's
got stems in it and eventually I get a
bag where I can get 10 skinny joints out
of it
so now my three turned into five and my
five turned into ten and all I had to do
was go to the A train and sit in the
last car
because he ate on the last car in a New
York City subway when I was growing up
that's where everything went on how did
you look how did you know you're on
subway yeah all right so the trains are
like 12 cars 10 cars how do you know
that everybody knows it really yeah I
started smoking when I was 12. really
yeah
one thing 12 years old yeah 12 years old
yeah that's Middle School yeah 12 years
old 12 years old in New York when I grew
up and basically you just sell it you
roll it up you sell it in the last car
the A train you know there's always
people going to the city going to work
they want to get a quick Buzz before
they hit to go to work and it was easy
to sell and it was pretty safe you know
in the dream because you transact in the
train pretty much just sit in the last
car and you lose joints loose joints or
I used to do it also in Washington Park
right by the Statue of Liberty you know
down Wall Street
um I took a job a lot about my age I
took a job as a messenger foot messenger
back then we'd have computers we used to
deliver millions they trusted million
kids with millions of dollars stocks and
bonds and deposits to be a messenger and
go all around World Street go to this
building or that building you may get
deposit here you go to this bank here
and that's what I do and then during
lunch I'd sit in the park and sell those
joints so that's how you sustain
yourself eventually I got up to a pound
a week
um
I was already like 16 by then all right
I was selling it by the ounce too so it
wasn't that hard we're not worried about
going to jail or like the police
one time I got busted on the train you
know what the cop did he took the weed
away he kept it it wasn't like that
everything was corrupt when I was a kid
I was born in a cesspool of corruption
and criminals in New York everything you
got away with anything especially if you
greet somebody you know I mean it was
it's the way it was it's all about the
hustle baby the hustle I grew up with
pimps prostitutes drug dealers uh
Killers all that [__] Jewel uh burglars
you name it everything cars cars is a
big thing stealing cars that was a big
thing where I was growing up so you're
scraping by when you're around 12 years
old what about education were you in
school or anything like that believe it
or not when I was very young
my mother was showing she was nuts in a
lot of ways but she wasn't stupid
and when I was very young up until about
the age of nine or ten from first grade
to fifth grade
I actually went to private school
because she would go in there and say oh
I'm a poor Jew can you give us a
scholarship and let my son in and all
this [__] and then it worked out but I
had to change schools every year because
part of the deal was they said fine
we'll give your son a free education but
you have to volunteer at school and work
there
well that [__] everything up part of
my language because she was nuts is she
coming there and the teacher would come
to me says Benjamin you're a nice boy
but your mother we can't deal with her
you got to go and she'd get me kicked
out of school but then she find another
school to take me in so I got a good
education for five years of my life and
I never went one did High School
eventually I kind of went to Junior High
for a little while I got back with my
father my sister I got bounced around
between Queens Brooklyn Manhattan Hell's
Kitchen but you know I went to Junior
High but I never made it to high school
not one day I knew I had to get high I
wanted to go to school learn for hold on
Ben you know what before we go into that
I do have to say that you seem
incredibly busy and I'm sure it's a lot
to organize all the real estate property
showings employees contractors and
everything else you have to do workflow
like this is just a never-ending task
but fortunately I think our sponsor
bittrex24 would be able to help you out
bittrex24 is an all-in-one platform that
could replace multiple software tools
and streamline your business another
thing that's crazy about bittrex 24 gram
is that they're currently the world's
largest CRM and project management
platform and the best part especially
for someone like me who likes saving
money is that they're completely free to
use you can manage your projects tasks
team Communications and more all in one
place with one of their over 35 free
tools yeah and you could uh set it up so
that you could shave the mustache right
looks terrible anyways Graham from
customer relationship management it to
marketing automation there's something
for you regardless of how big or small
your business is my personal favorite is
the project management calendar which
has been an absolute Game Changer in
planning out my daily tasks except for
shaving the mustache buddy it's
available on the cloud on mobile or for
you techies as an open source software
that can be installed on your own
servers and is fully customizable say
goodbye to switching between multiple
tools or paying a whole bunch of
subscriptions everything you need is all
in one place with bittrex 24. so try it
for absolutely free using our link down
below and take your workflow to the next
level for good so again check them out
with the link down below to get started
today and now Ben I'll let you talk
again but why stop at weed you mentioned
like pimps and like all these other
things why didn't you I wasn't a big
weed smoker or nothing you know I mean
you know dip in there but no I was born
to the money part of it okay you know
but then I saw that if I tried to go
expand into cocaine or heroin like my
uncle he moved millions of dollars worth
of heroin if I started getting involved
with that then it gets very very
dangerous very dangerous yeah it's a
whole other world I don't want to be
part of so I didn't go into hard drugs
or anything like that yeah that was
that's the death sentence but by the
time you were 16 and moving like you
said about a pound a week like I I know
that's like a ton that is like I'm not
even selling them in 161 ounce bags it's
not really it was a highly profitable
what happened was you know I worked out
in a village
um where I worked for I took a job
working for a company that was in the
clothing industry it was
they actually owned chaps by Ralph
Lauren
um you know a lot of divisions of
different types of clothing you know
they had designers and all this stuff
and my job we didn't have computers back
then you know what a Telex machine is I
used to have to communicate with the
feed telexes to a machine that would
communicate to Hong Kong Taiwan career
and I'd sit like an idiot feeding tapes
and running copies of people and running
errands and I had a job but I was around
all the designers and the designers in
the village
you know people are designed clothes for
Ralph the red and all in them
you know let me tell you I I've yet to
experience see too many people that were
really good artistically and it didn't
indulge in some sort of
Vice
anyway they all like smoke weed in a
village so they used to ask me hey you
know we get some good stuff and yeah I
can get you whatever you want So
eventually you know each person would
end up buying me like 16 different
people would each end up buying like uh
an ounce you know an ounce wasn't that
big it was a nice little bag rolled up
and you know and uh so I have about 16
clients but roughly you give or take and
uh once a week they all want to announce
that I'd have to go to these divisions
anyway all over New York to deliver
stuff so I do I'll do my deliveries
until the vice president find out and
then he can fired me interesting so
you're doing that and then you have the
court date which then eventually I did
something that I shouldn't have I did uh
uh oh yeah the guy fired me so I kind of
took revenge on the company and um
got caught what what was the Revenge the
Revenge what was the Revenge you're
shutting down my weed business
uh the Revenge was I got a bunch of big
tough guys from Rockaway
to go and help me clean out my desk
but we accidentally cleaned out about
other desks too and stuff so
what do you mean by cleaning out desks
you know when you get vibrant job you
take your stuff which in a box and you
get the hell out you're right well we
did the whole goddamn office we cleaned
everybody out
wow anyway so you know I got caught
because I you know I wasn't thinking you
know I didn't figure well of course
you're gonna know that's got to get
fired right anyway so they put two and
two together and I brought a bunch of
big giant African-American guys with me
to help me and um
anyway so I got in trouble for that and
that's what caused me to really I had to
really make a decision you know the
judge was going to put me in a real jail
for you know like an adult
um for probably 18 months and
um I didn't want to do that so I joined
the army and the Army saved my life you
know and the Army took care of me sent
me to Germany taught me you know some
good office skills
I actually hustled real estate in
Germany too when I was a soldier there
how was that because we didn't have
enough housing for the soldiers
so
a lot of people had a rent off base
especially if you had a family
so I cooked up with a guy was like he
was Italian but he spoke German anyway
he would rent apartments to the GIS
okay so I was like the middle guy
between the we called the um what they
call the German Market there was a word
for it the uh you don't know you're
polish
um anyway you know the Germans live in
town and then I would rent apartments to
GIS bring him got people that needed
apartments to rent and then he charged
the landlord to feed a German landlord
he also charged the Americans a fees he
double-ended it and then he'd give me a
couple hundred bucks every time I read
the department out so I would always you
know do that rental thing while I was in
Germany
what do you learn in the army what do
they teach you how to kill no I was I
really wasn't like being in the Army I
was in a civilian related job what
happened was long story short I went to
take the test
to get in the army guys take a test you
know and where are you scoring that test
determines your selection of what types
of jobs you want to train you in so I
took the test the first time I [__] it
up I didn't sleep last night the night
before I was partying and I went and
took a test I really screwed up the guy
gives me a list for like a few things on
it you know probably you know like
infantry or yes you know
some dangerous job so he said you know I
know you're smarter than this why don't
you take this book go study it
all right come back in a week and take
tests again
and I did so I took the book I found
somebody to help me study we studied a
book I went through the thing a week
later I take the test and the list comes
to me this long
and I said tell me the easiest job that
number one will help me when I want to
get out and get a job civilian related
job
and where are all the women at
okay because number one I want to be
around women right okay and two I know
the women don't work too hard in the
army
so he said transportation's for you so I
became a traffic management coordinator
so I learned transportation and what
Logistics moving [__] yeah it sounds
fancy what what is that job basically it
was all types of things I worked at
airports moving troops overseas all the
time because we Charter airplanes you
know and then we fill them up with gi's
and send them everywhere in the world I
worked in Germany where I was
responsible for container shipments that
came in to the port we had to keep track
of the containers because we had to pay
by the day for those containers to The
Container companies so the military run
up a big giant Bill the container were
coming off the ship we'd pick it up in
one of our trucks we take it out to one
of our posts then had to come back empty
and I had to track all this [__] I also
did military moves where we had to go
through towns I had to call the mayor up
and tell them we're coming through and
make sure we had enough clearance for
the tank so we didn't knock off a side
of a 200 year old building and get a
multi-million dollar bill from the town
it was very it was all types of
Transportation I did and then I could
have stayed that field too you know I
brought it done well I don't know
transportation is big money so you know
I did that for a few years in Germany
and then they sent me to San Francisco
to work in the San Francisco Airport
because that's where we sent all the
guys to the Far East you know Japan
Philippines Navy Air Force Marines
everybody I said I can't afford San
Francisco it's too [__] expensive so
they said well go to Oakland
all right I went to Oakland working the
airport there we had Mac flights
it was less expensive but very dangerous
I mean I thought New York was dangerous
Northern California back in the 1980s
was probably one of the most dangerous
places I've ever experienced what made
you people were different they didn't
even care you could beat the hell out of
them you could put them in jail they
didn't care and when cocaine and crack
hit Oakland California it destroyed it
I mean it was really sad but I got into
affordable housing there I started I
rented an apartment in a GI building
where mostly military guys that worked
at a naval air Hospital lived even I was
working at the airport in the Army
um and I rent an apartment in the uh
manager there she gave me 50 bucks a
month off my rent just to pick up the
garbage around the building which was a
lot back then to me 50 bucks my rent was
500 I knocked 50 bucks off I already had
a three year old a three-year-old kid
when I got there I had to keep when I
was here I had my oldest son when I was
18 in Germany
um and his mother
didn't tell me that you know a father
was a sergeant major
so if I didn't marry her I you know
would have put me in jail she was only
16. anyway
um
so I had a kid yeah and then me and her
didn't work out she was a nutcase so I
ended up taking him and living on my own
you know raising him and to this day he
runs my company yeah
um German no she's American she was a GI
brat got it okay so basically I got to
Oakland I started helping with the upon
building
you know I got to be the owner of the
apartment building he was a really cool
guy you know he had all the fancy cars
and toys and you know he was looking
pretty good and I said [__] I want to be
like him so
basically you know the lady old lady I
managed the building
well what happened was um yeah the old
lady was answering the building you know
I helped her out more and more and he
started noticing he was doing better he
was making more money I was helping to
clean out Apartments helping him getting
turned over helping them get rented he
was making more money
so we got to know each other when you
make people money they want to know who
you are
so she accidentally fell down the flight
of stairs and I became the manager
was she fine
which was fine yeah it was an old lady
filled in a flight of stairs that
happens and she could be your manager
anymore wow
geez happens the accidents happened in
life yeah you never know it actually
could happen just walking out the door
to his house right now
be careful jacket
anyway
educator manager and I was in the army
and this guy's doing really well and
then I turn around and I said hey my
time's up in the Army and he actually
offered me fifty thousand dollars to
re-enlist for another 40 years but they
wanted me to change my job or go into
something real military like bomb
finding or something mining or some [__]
and he wanted me to go to career and I
really didn't want to do that especially
I'm raising a three-year-old kid on my
own so he said no no no you stay with me
get out of the army come to work for me
full time I'll pay you what the Army's
paying you and then some and I'll make
you rich we'll own all kinds of real
estate together and and you'll you'll
have a great career in real estate how
long did it take until that moment to
facilitate that relationship with that
guy like was this like a year in the
making
I moved there let's see 83 to 86 in
Germany I moved there in 87.
during 80 1987 for a year I worked with
him and then in 88 I got out of the
military and worked full-time for him
and it turned out he was a builder he
built a lot of Section 8 housing around
Oakland and he was also building
mansions in the hills of
of uh I don't know if you don't know
Northern California at all it was called
uh Lafayette Orinda and all these up in
the hills in this real high-end area
it's a very colorful guy and he was real
smart he was into banking he knew all
kinds of [__] but I was the guy to do
all his dirty work so I get out of the
army and I says okay and he hands me a
big ring of keys like the old jail
movies would have a big ring of keys No
Labels on them no nothing he hands me a
big ring of keys and a 38 pistol
and he says here you go
and give me the addresses of about three
or four buildings he built around town
and I had to go in there and assess the
situation what's vacant what needs to be
fixed up what needs to get rented
and I did and I was real good at it
and uh so I learned everything he wants
to know about Section 8 housing I mean
because I learned from the housing
inspectors then once it taught me the
housing has already taught me how to run
because I do inspections with them or
learn the rules and fill out contracts
and all that so I got really good at it
and um and then we grew and then he made
me a bunch of promises and he didn't
really keep him at first so I said well
all right I got married again another
kid
excuse me I gotta get out of this I'm
living and then the neighborhood turned
bad even worse yeah what happened was I
saved his ass
the building we lived in was
predominantly rented in Navy people that
worked at the Naval Hospital up the hill
then the government shut down a naval
hospital
now he was subject to the neighborhood
people he didn't have that direct flow
from tenancy more military so he's
sitting there in an empty building he
could have went bankrupt but I took my
ass down to the Housing Authority
downtown I made Flyers up I put people
in my goddamn car I drove them over to
the building I take their baby carriages
I put people in wheelchairs in my car I
had a stationary it was real cool a full
wheelchair put it back in a station
wagon I'd take people and I'd do
whatever I could to get that place
rented up and I did
so now I became a Section 8 building but
he made more money he was a rough
building advantage and I lived there
I lived with it so I created this really
rough atmosphere and I had to live in
the middle of it so after a while I said
listen I can't live here anymore I gotta
move on you know you told me we wouldn't
do this we're gonna do that and we ain't
doing nothing you're building big fancy
mansions while I'm here in the hood
and I left them
and I went out and applied for a job
with all the experience I had from six
to eight housing I was worth something
in the market nobody wanted to do that
kind of real estate so I went to some
Big Shot company that was building big
buildings in San Francisco and had all
kinds of affordable housing stuff and I
took a job with them
and I got to you know got moved up to
ladder with them because nobody you know
I mean I I had experience in the streets
yeah I didn't know how to just process
the paperwork you know with the
government all that I knew I had to deal
with the tenants I didn't care I could
deal with a bum on the street or I could
deal with anybody it didn't matter
and I could deal with drug dealers I
could deal with criminals it just didn't
matter I mean you know I had that type
of grown up I grew up in that [__] so
basically I took a job at a company the
company was really good it did a lot of
big stuff I learned a lot I worked with
HUD worked with the state worked with
the cities
um they promoted me and promoted me and
gave me more and more buildings to
oversee and uh but I realized I was only
going to get to that one level with them
they weren't going to let me in
ownership right and the money's in the
ownership but if you can manage other
people's [__] you can own your own [__]
you just need the money to do it in the
financing so I sorted these good old
boys they weren't gonna let me go any
higher so I was getting a little
frustrated with that you know stuck in
about whatever I started working there
for about 30 grand a year I think I was
making 100 when I left and that was a
lot of money back what year was this
it's going to be early 90s right yeah
somewhere in the early mid 90s so here I
am
I go but you know oh so I do I was I did
save some money and I started buying
little [__] boxes in Oakland and fixing
them up
while I was working for them so I was
starting to buy my own stuff I buy crack
houses that were all boarded up I buy
all the [__] on the courthouse steps
nobody else wanted because they didn't
have the balls to go in the neighborhood
I mean they were there were places where
people refused to own property because
they're so dangerous
um you ever heard of black panthers
the real ones you know the back in the
60s the movement this is like their deep
ground headquarters Unfortunately they
moved away from you know helping the
community and black people into a lot of
drugs and stuff like yeah blah blah blah
anyway it's very dangerous so I started
buying my own stuff so what happened
the guy that I used to work for reached
back out to me says hey you know I'm
losing my shirt can you come back take
over my buildings again and I said sure
I'm now a management company my brother
came down from New York got his broker's
license because he was brilliant and um
we opened up at our little real estate
office
guess where we opened the office up
across the street from the Housing
Authority we are now these all right
section 8 landlords
go to place if you want anything to do
with subsidized housing or you know or
if you know so we saw do a management so
we said fine we'll take it on for
management he started paying his fee
management
and then he started saying hey you know
I got some money you want to do some
deals I said fine but you put up the
money I'll find the deals I'll fix them
up you put up all the money and we'll be
50 50 partners and we did it and we
started just you know I started flipping
deals I had his money the guy opened up
Banks the guy had big bucks
but you know so basically we grew grew
grew we ended up with maybe I don't know
500 Apartments spread out everywhere
more maybe more we brought up because I
would I would I don't know if the right
term to use but I would pretty much
blockbust something I call blockbusting
I mean I would buy a building on one
Street
and then turn around and
fill it up with Section 8 and we get
kind of rough and then everybody else in
that street would want to sell with me I
go to the next guy say Hey you know when
I tell my partner you know he bought
this building next door and you know
it's going to get bad here you better
sell now before it gets worse so we
ended up buying a whole bunch of block
from everybody and I did that in
Stockton California I did an Oakland
um you know so we brought up a lot of
stuff but then he got older and and then
um I knew I didn't want to stay in
California too long I met my first my
present wife and I didn't want to start
a family in California because we lived
on the top of a hill I grew I started
the bottom of the hill and as I made
more money I moved to the middle of the
hill and then I got to the top Skyline
Boulevard but you're looking down on the
[__] Hood who the hell wants to be
the king in the hood so I said we got to
get a California you know I was the
lawsuits were killing me
they see you for no reason out there
especially if you're a landlord the
politics the crime I hate it I don't
want to raise no more kids here and by
then I'm already raising two kids by
myself
so we both decided let's go to Florida
you know I ended up in Florida after my
whole tour of Duty in California I did a
tour of Junior Germany well first I did
a tour of Duty in New York growing up or
served time call it would you like then
I served time in California
and then from California I went to
Florida
and that's my life story now you know
and did you continue working with this
other guy we did some stuff together but
don't even buying them out because you
got kind of old you don't want to work
anymore you don't want to get involved
how are you able to buy them out did you
get a loan against his portion or how by
the time we got to Florida I had enough
money to either I could we always
refinance every time we bought a
building we bought a building we fixed
it up we refinanced and we got all our
money back so now we're into believing
for nothing or sometimes we take more
than we got we'd we'd end up pulling out
millions of dollars out of properties
after we just bought it fixed it up and
refinanced it depending on how much you
know Equity we built up in it by fixing
it up the Management's a big key to that
because you know the man a lot of people
don't manage their properties right okay
they spend too much money they don't
charge enough rent to the market and
that you know the the noi determines
what the value of the property is so we
build up the Noy we refinance and make
money on the deals and borrowed money is
tax free money did you know that
California
you knew that yes oh well very good
Jack's a homeowner he's a homeowner
bought a house a year ago
congratulations oh it's been like a year
and a half year and a half yeah so you
know you can borrow money all the time
you want put it in your pocket and it's
not going to be a taxable event till you
sell a property
so there you go yeah that's my story I'm
sticking to it then I bought him out and
my oldest son how much was it to buy him
out came to business with me
um we owned like two buildings together
and uh whatever we determine the market
value was the executive position you
know I just bought it from him and then
um bought them out wrote them a check
you know I had money by the time I left
California
10 million five million no it wasn't
that much I think we I owned a couple of
million in each building we have like
three buildings all together was like a
couple of million bucks I took over all
the debt yeah that was the main thing it
was a lot of debt right I probably have
a lot of debt on them you know and then
how did that expand through the 2000s
real estate bust because that must do
after I got rid of him yeah I bought the
shooter every day I could yeah I mean
when I came to Florida
I blowed up everything I could and then
I kind of it wasn't a mistake but I did
dib and dab in Texas in the Houston area
problem was
I bought in Houston then Katrina hit
and when Katrina hit everything from New
Orleans and all that [__] floated into
Houston and [__] it all up but I
bought a thousand apartments in Pasadena
Texas on one block once a thousand
Apartments all one block 110 100 unit
buildings I thought I was stealing and I
paid 17 a door
but
there's a reason why
all money you know all cheap prices the
reason why it's cheap I learned a lot
when I was in Texas but my oldest son
was already he drunk out of college
he was in college material you know none
of my boys were except this one
hopefully
um he came to work for me and he already
started working for me in Florida
imagine Apartments so I sent him to
Texas and he bailed my ass out by living
there and running everything and you
know so that worked out uh we did a lot
of [__] in Houston too and we got the
hell out but I did a lot of stuff in
Florida all up and down Florida and back
then it was money to make because you
could buy [__] for 40.50 a door
you could raise the rent you could fix
the place up you could trim your
fattening expenses and you can increase
your inner Y and the place will be worth
70 or 80 a door
it's all about the numbers so that's
basically what we did and we've done
thousands of them
I can't even count I mean I have a
resume I stopped using adding on to it
so we did Apartments our whole life all
right we and then we graduated from the
low-income [__] to b-class and then we
never really did a high a class that was
always too expensive to make sense
expensive to do what to run them and
then what happened was when I married my
wife her I inherited her little sister
and raised her like my daughter she
wanted to go to school for the hotel
business
um all the boys were in apartments she
wanted to try hotels fine she got her
Masters in hotels we stole we took her
and the professor who's brilliant
uh our teacher at school we stole them
from school and we bought a hotel and
then we bought another and then we
bought another now we have about we had
half a dozen hotels and then this guy
was so smart we didn't care we'd buy
anything Marriott's Holiday Inns eating
care it was brilliant so um we grew in a
hotel business but Apartments dried up I
couldn't afford them everybody got the
apartment game so now here we are we
can't find those deals on apartments
anymore what are we gonna do we're
selling our [__] off at the top dollar
we're making money we're getting 1031
into and hotels are tricky because
they're a business they're not real
estate it takes a lot of your time
there's a lot of responsibilities a lot
of moving parts
so we started going to retail so we
started buying shopping centers up hope
preferably grocery anchor type you know
so we started buying shopping centers
and then we brought up a shitload of now
we go on Publix's Winn-Dixie's then I
started also looking at well I want to
slow down a little and get part of my
you know it's all about adjusting a
portfolio I'm sitting here with 25
assets I have to manage at all times so
here I am getting older I don't want to
blow up in the management side of it I
like the way it is because my kids
running it let me buy some retirement
assets so I started buying some Home
Depots some lows you know big big name
companies we have nothing to do it's
triple net you know triple net is Right
very good okay it'll be a test later
so I started buying some triplets and I
Diversified my portfolio we just sold
out of our last apartment buildings not
that long ago we sold Starwood for 91
million he said well take everything so
he took all my about it um the guy Barry
um from Starwood Capital out of Miami
he's okay big companies so Capital they
sold Starwood to Marriott wow so he does
a lot of affordable housing he took all
affordable housing away from us and now
we 1031 into some more big retail stuff
and I still got a little piece I got to
buy but um so you know I was doing the
1031 I'm always looking before just hit
31 so I'll have it lined up and a lot of
times if I find a really good deal I
don't want to miss it I'll do a reverse
1031 you know what that is I don't know
what it is but I don't know why have you
spoke today what I'm just kidding I
think it's probably the opposite okay so
basically reverse tender or you know
reverse I've never heard of it okay
reverse 1031 will save your ass yeah
right basically if you know you're gonna
sell something
all right and you know you're going to
have to replace it and you have
tremendous gains on there and you don't
want to pay that you want to defer to
text what you can do is you can go out
and buy the replacement property before
you sell you have six months to the six
month rule so instead of having six
months to replace it you got six months
to sell your property because you're
already acquired to replace from
property of course you're gonna have to
come up with the money to do it but if
you know you're gonna go sell something
for 10 million dollars why wait till you
sell it and just start looking you're
under the clock looking right clock's
ticking don't if you got the money do it
beforehand do a reverse 1031. now what
happens when you sell your property you
get all the money because you already
replaced it right they're verse 10 31.
interesting that's what I've done many
times so I'm always looking for the next
deal because whether or not my property
is sold yet or not I want to cover that
1031 and I don't want to be on the the
clock you know ticking on me but this
also assumes you have the cash on hand
to be able to buy some got out of the
cash on hand to buy the replacement
property before you sell your own
property
but you know you can Finance it yeah
what are you what are you buying now
because I'm looking at commercial now
for the first time ever so I got some
cash I've been saving the last few years
I wanted to buy a triple net something
here in Las Vegas everything right now
is trading about six to six and a half
percent doesn't seem like it's worth it
because I'm getting I could get 5.2
right now in treasuries all right so
where's the episode right now we're in a
weird Market yeah all right and I don't
like to get too political but I think
the the government is totally [__] up
everything I mean you Jack the interest
rates up and now we got Banks falling
apart because they brought into
treasuries and all those other stuff
that ain't worth what it was so brings
the value to Banks down you heard about
the bank thing going on now that's all
because the interest rates interest
rates control the world and everything
they control lines of credits of
businesses they control people buying
homes they control businesses uh
commercial property they control
everything so right now we're in this
weird Zone everybody that owns real
estate wouldn't me I got a few hundred
million for sale right now it's going to
the market I don't want to swallow the
fact that I need to raise my cap rate
don't make sense if you pay to bank six
percent interest or more
and you get a six cap there's no goddamn
property you're working for free there's
no purpose and point being in real
estate you get six percent of your down
payment big deal like you said you go
get a treasury for that you go get a
tax-free immunity Bond even better but
now the crazy thing is I'm looking at
properties I'm calling them up and they
say we already have two offers on it and
so where the offer is coming 10 31 10
31. right now the only business that's
keeping uh real estate deals going to
1031 deals
keeping them going keeping the prices
down because all the people in
California so all that [__] made all
that money they don't want to pay
millions of dollars out to the
government for taxes they get a 1031 it
still pays even though they're not going
to be making money in a real estate they
could be saving millions in taxes I just
did my tax return
I don't know how I made money in 21 but
I did you know covert was over commute
gonna come back anyway long story short
I would definitely 10 31 and pay the
government Millions dollars taxes so
basically the only real estate if you
want to make money right now in real
estate you have to get your hands dirty
and the only way you're going to do that
and I'm just telling you what I'm doing
yeah because yeah I I like to see people
make money you know I don't understand
why a lot of real estate guys hide all
the time oh no I don't want nobody know
what I'm doing
it's not for everybody
okay everybody should imagine if
everybody succeeding in life imagine if
everybody helped everybody what a great
world it would be you know guys like him
would have a purpose in life yeah I keep
telling them I keep telling them so
basically this is what we're doing right
now and you should try to look into it
yourself if you can
you gotta I only believe in one type of
real estate right now not Office
Buildings they're getting crushed and
you can't repurpose them if you try to
turn them into Apartments it's a
nightmare your muscle tear the building
down and rebuild it with the zoning and
the plumbing and electrical and the
bathrooms in the kitchens it's a
nightmare I've seen guys doing they lose
their shirts all right so you can't
offices are dead everybody learn from
covert you don't need to work and big
enough disabilities full of people
anymore you can work at home you can
work in your car this guy probably works
in the toilet uh with his laptop it's
called the wework so
basically
you know offices are out I won't look at
them all right
Apartments is still too expensive
because everybody in their grandma got
in the apartment business why because
it's easy you give somebody a place to
rent you collect the [__] rent if
something breaks you're responsible for
you fix it and what else is there to do
all right simple all right so
performance is still way overpriced plus
because the interest rates being so high
and people are at an all-time low for
mortgages right now and nobody's buying
houses trust me I know I got a 12
million dollar house I just lowered the
price down to 10 and a half
is that that's yours person is that the
house I went to no no no you went to my
new house yes
at the hottest time in the market by the
time I fixed the goddamn place up they
started jacking the rates up and how's
the mark crashed so basically rent is
still going to maintain because people
aren't buying houses they have to rent
well supply and demand it is a big
demand of uh tenants then the supply is
going to cost more money simple so you
can't find any decent apartments right
now okay the only thing I'm looking at
is what I call you might call it
essential what I call it necessity
retail hair nails food
Chinese to go take out uh you know
anything that's necessity anything
Amazon the internet can't give you okay
so I'm buying up grocery store shopping
centers or you know essential shopping
centers with stuff like that in them
yeah find them with some empties that
are mismanaged or some old mom and pop
type places put a little lipstick on
them make them look like a nicer place
for people to want to come shop make it
look better for the business owners fix
the parking lot fix the roof put a
little paint on it and fill the empty
spaces why because when you buy them the
empty spaces are free you're buying on a
cap rate if you buy something you're
buying it based on what the income is
you know why the cap rate
if it's got empty spaces there's no
value in those empty spaces you're
getting real estate for free
so you're gonna go out and find some
distressed retail and then you have to
figure out how to rent it you know
they'll still sit around find an agent
you know that specialize in it put up a
nice sign reach out to companies you
know we do we cold call we just scored
when a company called Marco's Pizza they
want to rent three locations from us in
our shopping centers all over town
you know you look at who's growing what
what companies are popping up but stick
to necessity what Amazon can't sell you
and what you can't buy online all right
stuff like that what do you think of
doctors offices Law Offices Medical is a
specialty yes medical medical you can do
well yeah but it's all about the demand
is there demand in that location for
medical every shopping center I has has
a dentist has a hearing aid guy has uh
you know certain type of medical you
know things that people like to you know
you see them in retail places Medical
Office Buildings can do well but you got
to make sure you can keep them full the
problem with medical right now is a lot
of doctors have given up their private
practices why you know why they can't
afford the freaking malpractice
insurance insurance has killed the
doctor's business
so what they do is they have to go under
the umbrella of a hospital and typically
it'll move in wherever the hospital is
at and get you know where they were
located and they'll feed them clients
and they'll protect them so you got to
be careful with medical medical is great
if you could keep it full and there's a
need for Darkness to to want to have a
business in that area practice
Aaron he's not he's out of the room but
Aaron
took me over and showed me a a technical
school where they teach nursing okay
right near our house
schools are great but you have to check
the underlying
uh money that's behind the company is it
traded on the stock exchange is it a
small company is it a big company how
their income is what you know you got to
really be careful because you know
you're talking about big some of these
places that pay 50 Grand a month right
well if you're counting this guy to pay
you 600 Grand a year in rent you better
make sure that company's making money
and you know that's a mom and pop rinky
things can go out of business so you
know you have to check the businesses
assets and make sure it is strong before
you rent to them and what sort of cap
rate do you look for on something like
that because it's got to be at least an
eight to even make sense right now I
mean you know is it worth it if you
could get five and a half percent let's
say guaranteed right now is it worth it
to take the risk for eight no eat a
little boy what's up is it a little boy
the order or The Waterboy yeah I got
this for myself because I used to drink
it but here you go I hope I can trust
you if you opened it yet uh I did I
don't know where it came from anyway um
yeah came back to what you're saying
um basically what are we saying is it
worth it is it worth it
cap rates it's a market you know
everything's a market right now it is
the market we're in you used to pay for
cap for a Starbucks right now you get
them for five and a half maybe six I
haven't seen six not here because you
don't you don't pay state tax correct
but if you go to a taxable State you'll
see it just you see fair enough yeah
that's true so basically cap rates are
going up what do you do you sit around
and you're gonna have to you're gonna
have to ignite put a fire under your ass
if I see a Starbucks right now and
they're asking six cap
okay and you're not selling I'm gonna
offer from a seven
you got to get in there and now you
gotta you got a bargain you got a low
ball [__] basically Now's the Time To
Low ball and make the person realize I'm
gonna sit on my ass and make believe I'm
selling or am I really selling that's
what you got to do right now so I I
under bid [__] I lowball ship at least
25 percent okay if I see a nice product
you know cap rates are based on tinted
quality and look how long the lease goes
out what your responsibilities are uh
you know and and things like that so
what you want to do is you want to get
in there bargain right now and try to
earn a good deal because it's not going
to be handed to you not in this market
or do you think it's better to wait
let's say but eight months from now you
could be more aggressive than you can
today do you think things are going down
in a sense that you know sure you could
Bargain shop today but you could better
Bargain shop
the point is but what are you gonna do
from now till then sit on your ass
treasuries if you're making five percent
guaranteed that's not working I gotta
work for a living I gotta wake up every
day I gotta find another deal I got a
portfolio but for anybody else out there
who has the luxury you should always be
trying because the least it's gonna do
it's gonna give you the experience and
you're not gonna be afraid and you're
not gonna you're gonna learn a lot of
[__] I've learned [__] every day okay
you're gonna get in touch and you get a
network of Brokers you're going to know
who's selling what's going for this
what's the Walgreens going for right now
they got a Walgreens over here and sixth
cap but this guy he's willing to take a
seven you know you're learning the
market you're making offers it's part of
the experience you know real estate is
an experience
what does he do I just sit here I'm
still trying to figure that out he chose
this guy roped you in your paying this
guy for what I I'm still there's good
looks we've been trying to figure this
out for a while trying to get to the
bottom of this I don't know
so you got that look you know I'm not
gay and I don't go that way but okay I
appreciate you guys talking about
commercial real estate this is something
I have I I am talking about that's the
thing for me it's like I'm 24. I just
got my first property I'm just getting
started so I'll let you guys do what you
do with commercial because I don't have
something else you can do out there
right now you got a lot of Big Balls for
doing it which I'm looking at doing
because I got big balls at least my wife
doesn't say that but I think I do
um converting
hotels and motels that are killed in
covid and can no longer survive the old
mom and pop [__] he wants is always a
need for affordable housing
seniors love them too you could take two
shitty hotel rooms pop a door in the
middle rip out a bathroom pop in a
little kitchen you guys have a nice one
bedroom apartment but you got to buy
cheap and you can't spend a fortune
fixing it up so that's something I'm
really interested in doing I'm going to
call it Studio City
all right take all these old shitty
hotels where hookers go and druggies go
get rid of them clean them up picks them
up and and make them affordable decent
housing for people yeah what do you
think of affordable workspaces it does
seem like there is a need for like a wee
work where people could rent out their
own I think it's coming back yeah dude's
coming back because nobody nobody wants
to rent a tremendous mental office
anymore so this whole Community
communion whatever you want to call a
thing it works but it's got to be
location it's all about the right
location you gotta have those type of
people in that location you know the
hipsters and uh whatever they are
people that want to hang out and have
coffee with other people they don't know
and I don't know yeah marijuana is
legally you can have a smoke room you
know sure so for the average Layman the
person listening right now if they're
either just getting started in real
estate or maybe on like their second or
third or fourth property what would you
encourage them to do if they're buying
like residential real estate if you're
paying rent you should always consider
what can you buy for the money you pay
in rent
all right everybody should try to get
approved for an FHA loan if it's your
first time and don't buy a house
all right you're 24 years old you buy a
house yeah how much income does it bring
in uh 38 maybe I don't know the exact
numbers Jack rents at all the bedrooms
yeah I moved in yeah
so you rent out your bedroom yes and
what services are included in these
bedrooms what services some I know
prostitutions legally somebody rented
out furnished some I didn't it just like
women no no
it's not a whorehouse it's my friends
you're French yeah yeah so it's like an
orgy yeah okay
right now the bedrooms that's all that's
cool yeah but you know that only take
you so far you know but typically what
you want to do is you know a person out
there that qualifies an FHA loan wants
to buy a fourplex okay especially if
you're paying rent because at a minimum
even with today's rates
you should be able to live free with the
other three apartments are paying enough
to pay all the bills and everything and
you don't pay for anything
so you get an apartment for free all
right which should only Save Somebody
fifteen hundred two thousand dollars a
month or and then eventually you can say
well screw this and right you're on your
own apartment after a year
you can do that and then you got four
tenants paying and then you go out and
buy do it again you can do it with a
Triplex you can do a fourplex you might
be able to cash flow if you find the
right deal you think that makes sense in
this market it makes sense in any Market
you got to find a deal real estate is
all about finding the deal it's like
digging for buried treasure you know you
got to get a metal detector and find a
metal okay that's what real estate's all
about and once you find a deal
everything else is simple you find a
deal you figure out how to raise the
money whether you qualify you'll find
somebody to help you is finding the deal
is where you make the money what's
interesting to me is what you were
saying about load balling because for me
like I Peru Zillow and everything and I
see like what stuff's selling for I see
what they're asking and I'm just like
okay well this doesn't even make sense
because I bought a year and a half ago
the price is a lot lower the rate I got
was smoking look for the stuff that's
not selling
you go to the MLS and you look for
everything that's been sitting on the
market for over 90 days or even 60 if
you're one of your ballsy if it's
sitting on a market and ain't selling
better to get your offer than no offer
right that's exactly what I did and then
the worst thing that's going to happen
is you're going to find out what deer
Rock Bottom is they may not sell it for
the shitty offer you made them they
might you they might be here you might
be here but you might find a place in
the middle of meet but at least you'll
find out what they're willing to take
when you're lowball them so it pays the
low ball and in terms got a lot to do
with it too you come in here and you're
all kinds of strings attached oh I need
30 days to look at the plays and inspect
it and I need to finance a contingency
and I need this and I need that to get
to say all right waste my time with you
you got too many ways to get out of the
deal I got a guy over here with cash
ready to make a deal so contingencies
can really screw up a deal too you want
to give them clean terms quick close you
know as best you can and that's it hard
money maybe it's worth if you're risking
a 500 on something to go hard you know
to tie it up that's interesting so the
property I live in right now is cash
flow like based off of all the random
how much
to 300 bucks
I don't know the exact got a great
mortgage rate though 2.8 yeah fixed
that's great yeah yeah that's great and
what's interesting is I probably written
how many people are written one room
you're not written one no no one person
per room thank God oh my God it's a five
I'm picturing him with bunk beds
he's got the Las Vegas hostel going here
he's got five bunk beds I'll be smart
he's got big numbers and he goes around
wake up give me a hundred bucks it's a
great time you know you'd like this I
was renting out three it's a five
bedroom I had one room three other
people were renting other rooms and then
the fifth room was on the only one on
the bottom floor I Airbnb and it had a
lock on the outside it had a lock on the
outside it was a devil on the outside
don't know why the previous owners had
that but I had to remove that of course
before I had Airbnb guest stay there but
that's besides the point that what I was
trying to say was this house I was
shopping for probably about six months
and of course the real estate market was
going up when I was shopping it was that
time rates were still low which was nice
and this was the only property that
entertained my offer and this is also
the only property that I offered less
than what they were asking for every
other property that I was in like
sending in actual offers for I was
initially offering more houses everybody
got killed it right which one the house
everybody got killed in which one the
one I bought yeah yeah all right it was
a good thing but it was the only it was
the only property that actually okay
back with the funniest negotiator he
would call me and be like Ram I'm 10
over asking right now I'm like what
happened called the owner and he said he
had another offer and so I'd stop for
more like you were calling him to bring
down the prices I had no guidance so I
used to tell him what to do let's get
down to basis
yeah all right basics
basis
no not baseball not just that basis your
basis of real estate what you paid for
it okay all right so you bought the
property for how much 589 holy macaroni
500 what 80 89 589 how much money to put
down 20 20
580 is what 125 125 Grand you got tied
up in this house you owed to bank
another 460 or something right yeah all
right so how much your mortgage tax
Insurance uh Piti is 23 80. all in sorry
it's like 23 actually all in pi okay so
if we're talking variable expenses as
well talk about what do you pay for
every your mortgage taxes
is your payment every month includes
your taxes Insurance yes all right which
payment are we went to the bank it's
like 22.95 22.95 2300 bucks oh you're
smart you're locked in at a good low
rate you got 2 300 bucks going out to
the bank every month all right how much
how much you bring it in 38 probably 38
38 for 23 is what 15
no 100 a month
how much you're bringing in a month
on the house you collecting how much 3
800 a month in rent yeah yeah you're
paying out twenty three hundred dollars
yes so it's fifteen hundred dollars
three and five is eight he said 38
didn't he yeah he said 38 so okay so
okay so if the math are doing is 23 to
38 yeah
1500 bucks a month who's paying the
utilities you I am I pay for everything
how much utilities costs you want
probably brings me up to 35 in monthly
expenses if we're talking variable
expenses what about cable internet who's
paying for that all of that how much are
you expenses you got water you got sewer
you got garbage electric you got gas you
got like I said cable internet sewer I
mean a landscaper landscaper yes
I have a landscaper it's probably
realistically 35 3 600 per month is what
it's costing me in total with variable
expenses but everything yes utilities
a pool yeah yes how Pool Cleaner
included yes so you're into this you're
collecting 38 and you're paying out how
much thirty five thirty five thirty six
but you live there for free yes
actually I I did add a landscaper
recently which is 180 a month so that
might it might be 37. all right do you
live in there for free basically yeah
you're not cash flowing no but you're
living there for free we're saving you a
couple of grand a month probably at
least yeah or sleeping in that room
where all the stuffed animals a
month-to-month basis
I did used to live in that room yeah I
know I could tell by the stuffed animals
but if we include I hate to see what's
in your room tubby like big repairs
capex and all of that stuff I'm
definitely like he's got a refrigerator
wait wait wait okay so so let's
backtrack you gave you gave Jack great
advice so what you're saying is so for
example my wife and I I'm married if you
could believe it uh she has my
condolences
okay so my wife and I it's okay to be
fat but you can't be fat and poor what
dude I'm loaded he's loaded yeah you're
loaded all right you're full of it
you're loaded up so like an 18 wheeler
my wife and I think are in the first
position so I uh that you mentioned so I
think I want to go back to that and
reiterate so we're looking to buy a
house we have a bunch of money stashed
away now so you're telling me don't buy
a house is that like where you're
telling me don't buy a house listen it's
different if you got a family and kids
and all that stuff I'm talking about a
young person with no responsibilities 24
years old you ain't no kids do you no I
don't have any kids you're gay aren't
you yeah I figured that so you know you
ain't got no kids uh 24 year old
starting out she tried to buy something
where he's going to have you know make
some you know live for free at least or
cash flow I mean if you're stuck with a
wife and kid you ain't got kids do you
no kids there you go over those kids
um anyway I mean it's different you got
a woman to answer to you know it's
different or you tell her listen let's
not buy the house right now we're not
ready but you're loaded so what do you
care we're talking about people that
ain't got money
I'm telling Alex to wait I think I think
now's a good time it's very expensive
but now prices are coming down but guess
what his rent is so affordable it's way
cheaper to rent we're looking at prices
now like what Alex is currently paying
they wanted to raise his rent like 300 a
month he did get crazy man yeah so I
said let's go and take a look well we're
in Terror Department
three people well so he gets rid of the
security deposit but we're looking at
the other places for rent they're
cheaper and bigger and in a nicer
location than what he's currently
spending because everyone who can't sell
is deciding to rent right now so I think
rental prices are so cheap but now
they're trying to lowball people I want
to sell look at what's going stale in
the market if it's sitting on the market
it ain't selling and then you got a
permit for the kill you always start
poking the bear yeah and saying hey
what's this bear going to do I mean
that's the way it is but I can see him
in a double wide maybe making a triple
wide trailer exactly what you're saying
was the exact same case low balling and
uh it had been sitting on the market it
was the only one that worked out I mean
it always starts with the big giant
deals first yeah I'm reading articles
about guys that are leaving hundreds of
millions of dollars
just gone banks are taking their hits
today every day I get a a message or a
story a true story you know about a bank
just took 60 million 120 million loan
that's where it starts
the signals are there and it starts at
the top
and then starts trickling down
eventually everybody not everybody had a
30-year fixed rate like you did all
right A lot of people took their
mortgages out maybe 20 years ago 15
years ago all right they're gonna have
to either pay them off or they paid it
off the point is this anybody that's
going to need to refinance is screwed
right now
okay because the rates are so high and
the properties are not going to be worth
what they were worth so we're going to
see a lot of foreclosures we're going to
see the [__] hit the fan you just kind
of keep your eyes out it was the Wall
Street Journal that reported I think it
was 63 percent of mortgages are
currently below I think it's like four
and a half percent it was such a low
number it's good and I think 20 25 were
below three now but as time goes on but
that's assuming they were Finance
because I think a lot of people just
want to be locked in right just not
refinance I mean hopefully they all had
fixed rates right many years ago when
they bought a house right but what about
the people that took adjustables and you
know you're going to see a lot of it you
see what happened is a lot of houses
were brought up by commercial people and
they didn't take but they couldn't get
residential loans of those long rates
for locked in for so many years they may
have gotten five years interest rate low
on them you're going to see a lot of
[__] hit the fan and I don't know what
the hell the home builders are going to
do because they made plans two years ago
they no build developments and they had
projections and now those projections
are out the window and open downl
it's just kindly creeping in you know
but if you really want to get a jump on
it get out there and start knocking on
doors hey what do you want to do your
price properties on the market for sale
but you're not selling here's an offer
100 grand less
like I would take Millions less right
now than I would have took a year ago on
a lot of my properties I thought I had
stuff oh I'll sell this Home Depot all
day long at a [__] five cap [__]
I can't get it when I take a six maybe
show me some good terms you know what
one one percent cap rate is on a 20
million dollar Home Depot
two million bucks I think right two 100
Grand no 20 million 21 10 or 20 million
would be 2 million oh now he's gonna
have me find out this anyway
10 million dollars you buy a 10 million
dollar Dunkin Donuts or whatever
McDonald's whatever Home Depot you buy
10 million dollar property and a five
cap right that's gonna pay you 50 000 a
year in every million right
five percent so five percent of 10
million will be
fifty thousand five hundred thousand
dollars I'll collect thirty thousand
dollars in rent that's a five cap is
somebody gonna pay me ten million for
five cap no I may have to take a six cap
I need calculations
and it's hot in here and it's hot in
Nevada it is cold outside the AC in here
unfortunately because it it makes too
much yeah I can't have that no
absolutely not what do we do it's got a
sweet you just gotta sweat it yeah I
just talk louder it's good it's healthy
for your skin it's exfoliation exactly
no I think the cold is more preserving
you want to take a piece of meat it'll
go spoiled somewhere won't you but you
put in a refrigerator glass oil figure
that out true
rest of the podcast one of the issues I
see with Vegas right now is as I'm sure
you've seen driving around there's a lot
of homes under construction and a lot of
the community if they've stopped
building got the windows right there
yeah exactly but they've uh but they've
stopped building because they know
they're going to be in it for more than
what they could sell it for right now
because building costs are still fairly
high so it doesn't make sense and they
don't want to take a loss properties
because that's a bad comp for the rest
of the neighborhood so it kind of screws
them on them so they're just stopping
unless they get a great offer there's no
incentive for them to keep building or
selling but yeah so many houses
Banks
the banks are worried the first person
to worries the banks and the banks are
feeding them money to keep building now
the bank's going to say okay pull the
fire let's see what we got here and
they're going to say oh [__] these
properties are not valued at what we
thought they were going to be valued at
so therefore
the banks are going to get worried
they're going to be have too much LTV
tied against the property and oil TV is
Right loan value very good and the banks
are going to come in and say wait a
minute we're going to come up with some
other plan here what are you going to do
and they could there's always verbiage
in your loan documents that say the bank
has the right to come in and reappraise
the property and if the property does
not work what it was when they loaned
you the money cough up baby cough up and
if the guy ain't got nothing to cough
yeah I gotta get rid of it now I think a
lot of people are assuming the fed's
going to step in because they don't want
to be raising interest rates at the same
time that the economy is crashing at the
same time it's not a fit issue the banks
don't want to sit there like what
happened to no wait right
what happened to no wait and crashed was
that the banks are sitting on all this
goddamn properties all these loans and
that's the value of the bank the banks
only worked with loans autos of their
assets the bank is sitting there with a
10 million dollar loan with the property
is only worth 8 million or 10 million
even
that they're 100 leveraged no Bank wants
to be 100 leveraged
so it's it's good it's it's a crazy
Market we're in but hopefully you know
they'll top off stop raising these damn
rates and maybe we'll see them stabilize
down around five if so I think it's
reasonable I think the party days are
over I was borrowing money yet you don't
want to know
I was borrowing money in a one-month
Library one month libraries practically
zero the bank would charge me a point
and a half I was borrowing hundreds of
millions of dollars at one time at one
point five or six percent interest only
now couldn't you negotiate that lower I
was because I negotiated 0.9 plus so
whatever so far is plus nine when
recently yeah but it's all over the
world
a year ago a year ago or two or a year
and a half ago I was borrowing money for
less than two percent hundreds of
millions of dollars of commercial real
estate now I'm paying over six because
now they got rid of library because it
was crooked they were sofa called Bisbee
but silver rate is like what now it's
crazy now it's high
but it used to be if it's five now yeah
yeah I know but if it's five now
and I'm paying a point they have a topic
I'm paying six and a half right now I
guarantee you I'm paying out from just a
year ago
six million dollars more a year in
interest payments
and that's strict interest no principle
500 Grand a month are going to come out
of my pocket hey since you're loaded
over here can you make me a loan chubby
all right so that's basically the life
we're in what am I gonna do cry no I'm
going to sell off a bunch of toys and
sell off some assets that don't make
sense cash flowing no more
and try to get my hands in a bunch of
cash because the bargains are coming
they're coming believe me now I I take
it you're still cash flowing enough
though because you got to be around I'm
working for the employees and I'm
working with a bank I got 800 employees
with the hotels and all the other
[__] you know I'm working for the
employees and I'm working with a bank
I'm not cash flowing but little I'm cash
flowing probably doesn't even pay my
goddamn wife's freaking credit card bill
I don't know but anyway no I'm not I
gotta I gotta sell assets yeah and then
sell them to somebody else that's
willing to sit there and own something
with no real cash flow or they want to
type a bunch of cash at real estate
because they're in 1031. so what
happened in the meantime then was it
just like adjustable rate stuff that you
borrowed on did you take on new life I
didn't fix my rate I was a big fat
greedy Pig and I didn't know the party
was going to be over you didn't
refinance when the rates were low
okay I played a market whatever the
Libor was or sofa I paid a bank a spread
on whatever that rate is and that rate
changes daily
okay
and the rate was low for years and years
and years okay so I just whatever the
rate was you said it was 2.9 or
something point two okay I was paying a
couple of percent for hundreds of
millions of dollars I could have fixed
it at three I'm gonna pay that
every asset is different in commercial
real estate if it's a Home Depot it has
another 15 years on it took about 15
years really wow if you had the money
like I do to back it up I mean you know
let's face it Banks loan money to people
that have money they get the best rates
to the people that don't need it yeah
right okay so basically I could have
fixed my rates paid an extra point let's
say I was at two I could have paid an
extra point and fixed it off at three
instead now I'm paying six so I got
greedy I should have said you know what
the [__] could hit the fair and let me
pay an extra point it would have cost me
an extra couple of million a year but it
protects me
well now I got no protection and now I'm
paying six million a year
so that's life did you by the way did I
tell you I'm selling my Rolls-Royce he's
looking to buy it this one's the most
luxurious one you could buy I've I've
seen brand new 700 000 it's the ewb
extended it's like a limo have my life
now and mine is only two years old has 5
000 miles on it it's the most beautiful
luxurious car you could buy and you can
get it for for you today uh the Graham
stuff is special AIDS tell me 450.
forfeit no I'm not can't do four things
you can actually fit in this car this is
a car you could fit in Graham you can't
drive us around in the Ford GT I'm tired
I'm sitting like this I know you don't
try to squeeze buy the Rolls-Royce man
all right well Evangeline in the world's
not getting you in a Ford GT
so did you just not expect the FED to
increase rates as fast as they did I
mean they didn't think about it no this
clearly shows that they didn't take the
time to think about what the
repercussions are it clearly shows that
they're not really business people and
I'm sorry I'm not really into politics
because both of them have good and bad
too I'm not I'm not a republican Debra
I'm a little both I like the good in
both of them but Democrats are typically
not business people that's a fact
Republicans are and that's why you can't
trust them
so where are we living yeah well I like
to take the good from both and you know
and and just somehow I wish it was a
party that just they just did that but
they can't
because people are human
and humans don't like to get along now
what do you think right now about Dave
Ramsey's approach I recently had him on
the channel Chef different you're
thinking of Gordon Ranch Dave Ramsey the
anti-debt guy anti-deck guy he was wrong
but now he's right
it goes into Times everything is a time
you're in everything's a market you got
to go with the flow it's a roller
coaster ride you know and you gotta ride
that roller coaster and you have to
adjust yourself to what the times are no
I didn't never believed in all that I
believed I was I would not be where I'm
at today if it wasn't for debt if it
wasn't for debt I would have listened to
my father and be the garbage man he
wanted me to be a garbage man hang on
the back of a truck pick up garbage he's
saying hey you're Outdoors you get good
benefits you get a pension you live a
good life being a garbage man
but no I wanted to go into real estate
and the banks that would help me do it
it's all their money you know yeah so
you got to go into times right now I'm
thinking about writing a check for 100
million dollars and paying off 100
million dollars worth of debt when I go
home I may do that but then I have to
think about well if I do do that that
will increase my cash flow which will
increase my taxes so me paying 100
million dollars debt may not save you
all the money I think it is because I'm
in the 37 tax bracket so there's a lot
of things to figure you have to look at
your own situation and figure out what's
best for you yeah do you think do you
think it's worth it to buy right now in
cash
if you have the cash and you don't want
to pay the bank six or seven percent and
you could you know and you can uh you
can afford to part with the cash and not
leave yourself in a vulnerable position
you know cash is better now I don't want
to pay the bank six seven percent
but I may have to because I'm in a 1031.
there's a lot of different factors
involved it's an equation you have to
sit down and figure out what equation
works for you yeah
like you how many bedrooms are empty
right now zero zero bedrooms are empty
now have you thought about splitting the
bedrooms making one bedroom into two
bedrooms how many bathrooms you got in
this house one bathroom five bedrooms
one bathroom get in line everybody gets
a certain time they get to go to the
bathroom gets a bucket a bucket that's
better how many bathrooms you got three
three bathrooms very good but to be
frank okay so I bought this property
only planning on moving in two people
just a friend and uh two friends exactly
yeah that was my plan the only reason I
I got tenants in the other two rooms is
because I I like them the finances at
all sure it's nice but at the same time
I figure like in my own home the peace
of mind being able to work work on this
make more money it's there's a higher
Roi making sure I'm inspired in my own
home than there is another 800 or so a
month listen it sounds like to me you're
living for free which is a smart thing
thank you yeah now you're going to move
to the next level and get cash flow yeah
yeah well you can do like Germany did in
Germany it was crazy when you rent an
apartment in Germany
everybody has to take a turn helping
keeping the place clean like we lived
these buildings you've done in Poland
too the Europeans they don't [__] around
uh he knows if you rent a I rented a
billion when I was a GI in a building it
was like one two three four five six
apartments and it was a staircase right
every week everybody had to take a
different term mop and goddamn
staircases if you guys are listening
right now my housemates you should
definitely start telling everybody
everybody's got to take turns uh mowing
the lawn yeah and cleaning the pool and
you eliminated two bills right there
yeah that's a genius I'm not gonna raise
your rent but you kind of saw helping
out around here I got a question because
my next plan actually to be I haven't
told Graham this but I want to buy
property cash but I don't have enough
money to do that I want to buy property
cash but I ain't got no cash all right
this guy's got a good plan that's a
great plan somewhere somewhere in the
South or the Midwest somewhere like over
here because I have enough cash to do it
there
listen you can go a lot of places real
estate for probably nothing still
but you ain't gonna want to go to those
places you know why is the reason why I
did nothing just like when I went to
Texas I bought a thousand years of 17 a
door there was a reason why
you can't keep a thousand units full
your own goddamn competitor
plus when immigration came in had
tenants would move out
and all the other issues I mean it's all
relative you know you get to pay more
because you get more you're going to pay
less because you get less that's the way
everything works in life
so and I don't see you traveling far
away for what make a couple hundred
bucks a month how much cash you got
right now tell the truth the whole truth
nothing but the truth including the
stuff you stuff in your pillow
up to you jack uh everybody get ready
you're gonna tell us how much he's got
cash just cash in the bank money that
you could if you cashed in every well if
you liquid cash stock funds uh your coin
collection I don't know
thank God your your Woody call came back
your crypto came back my stocks crypto
came back
Rich I just had teeth work done no Rich
relative has left you any money no so
what do you got what do you got but if
I'm selling stock are we talking in a
Chase account how much money can you
raise right now in cash
600 Grand 600 Grand oh he didn't know
that you're in trouble now baby you're
not getting paid
he's been stashing you better find out
how much you're missing and who knows
what he's sitting on over there boy
what how'd you get all that money no
how'd you get away 600 Grand guy like
you 24. what's this I'm I I co-own it so
it's a it's like a I created this with
him so I would say it's all just a lot
of it's revenue from this and a lot I
did make a good amount of money
investing I got equity in my house which
is nice I live frugally accounting home
equity
[Music]
you're fired you're hired if I were to
the thing is I don't have expensive I
drive an old car I don't spend money
that's good you're 24 you shouldn't yeah
you know
and uh I mean so basically 600 Grand I
mean you know technically 600 Grand is a
25 down on what six times four is uh 2.4
million so you could go out and buy
something for 2.4 million
why not it's a bad idea I think with the
podcast oh it's a bad idea extremely
variable a lot of a lot of these
episodes we would run like break even or
a slight loss yeah just to be able to
track how do you get 600 Grand you want
to figure that out yes
investigator and find out if he's
personally got 600 Grand over his build
you need to know why yeah
check to see what's stolen around here
that's I mean that's it I mean if you do
have 600 Grand but you think that you
could go out and buy something for two
and a half million I feel like if I'm
taking on that much debt that's
literally I'm not saying you should but
let's say it was a deal of the century
and a bank was going to loan you the
money you could I'm not saying you would
but what you know put it this way 20
down to 25 down you could find a deal
right now you got to look and make sure
it's the right deal maybe you guys
should team up together
yeah no partners for me there we go so
that's it that's enough of my personal
finances all right okay I want to know
more about your personal life because
you are now losing six million dollars a
year just right interest can you tell us
a little bit more about basically I got
a portfolio and it's probably words and
I took everything I had all together and
threw it all in something
liquids assets real estate maybe 500
million
yeah okay that's okay
that's my story but why not at this
point
sell off the 250 pay off the other loans
let's just decide the problem is yeah Oh
you mean just pay off my loans and keep
the assets no no I'm talking about
seller properties to pay off all the
loans
uh okay and I've been 10 31 in since I
was in my 20s so for 30 years I pretend
31 and so my basis is very low I could
own a 20 million dollar property and my
basis you know basis means I could be
like a million sure so therefore if I
sold it into 20 million with no profit
even
I still got a 19 million dollar gain and
tax on 19 million of capital gains is 20
percent so 19 million would cost me
about 4 million bucks plus I got
recaptured depreciation 24
the net investment tax because the
bomber or something raises yeah there's
three point eight percent on top of that
yeah if you're cashing it more than a
million dollars oh and then I may have
to recapture the couple games I mean a
depreciation what I'm thinking about
doing is I'm thinking about going out
not selling my assets or even if I do I
can still sell them and I'm going to do
accelerated depreciation
you ever heard of that I've heard of it
yeah don't know what it is we're going
to accelerate depreciation
and get the write-off now but
I'm not really paying much tax because I
got no goddamn income because my
interest rate went up so high so that
doesn't really make a lot of sense
either but these are things I have to
look at but if I sell it if I do
accelerated depreciation and I sell a
property I don't have to recapture it
because 1031 you don't have to recapture
depreciation you defer it and everything
gets deferred till I die and then my
wife could step the basis she lives
happily ever after she marries some good
looking 24 year old like you and she
lives the rest of her life happy now
what do you think about them wanting to
get rid of the stepped up tax basis
because I mean even as it is right now
isn't that only after the first you know
he wants to get rid of the capital gain
he wants to get rid of 1031 all right I
don't think they're going to do that
I've seen that proposal but they wanted
to get rid of the stepped up tax basis
upon debt they wanted they wanted the
tax basis to say the exact same yeah
that would crush a lot of widows but
don't you have to raise the money to pay
this accident sell property no but
that's assuming they sell and the tax
bill could be more than a game no
basically what they're saying is that
that your tax basis would transfer to
let's say your air right and then if
they were to sell then they pay based on
your tax basis of the property not
theirs that would be a lot more taxes
they would end up with nothing but
that's if they were to sell the best
thing to do is if you want to get rid of
1031 that's fine if you want to get rid
of it get rid of it but it's going to
stop a lot of growth people aren't going
to grow as much and then you have to
give me stepped up basis all right
because at least I'll be saved I'll just
sell everything at step to basis and not
have to worry about paying tax to them
selling with the market prices it's
complicated what happened to what I had
what happened you keep drinking I drink
it all oh well it's hot as [__] in here
do you want it here I didn't know this
was going to be terrific iced coffee
this is the [__] hot box this is the
[__] sauna hour coffee come hang out
and Graham stuff in sauna box so how
much does it cost because your house is
massive what is the house what is the
value of the house uh right now it's
over 30 million 30 plus 32 to build
his career is over and yeah whatever and
he needed to sell it I bought a 50 cents
in a dollar I didn't want that house I
hated that house I hate that house I
like my old house it was a strictly
investment it was a 50 Cent so that deal
it was a brand new house 50 cents a deal
Irreplaceable you can't find three lots
of Bel Air Beach Impossible on the Gulf
of Mexico why not sell it move to the
other half my wife is offered me that
opportunity but I don't want to move for
a nice house with all the gadgets to
some older house and then she didn't
want to tear that [__] house of porn
drive me nuts fixing it up it's not for
me I'd rather just my outside itself the
scientologists offered me 29 once I
think really want to use it as one of
their headquarters
I got was a money but um anyway my house
should be worth about 30 million even a
bad market so what's that cost just off
of like the three lots yeah but like 20
000 square feet in and out the uh like
if you're if you're talking about like
all the variable expenses of owning a 30
million dollar house like luckily I was
the only thing I was smart on was my
mortgage I fixed my rate at two percent
I got a mortgage in my house I got 80
jumbo low to two percent
fixed rate for like 15 years 15 years
interest only baby interest only
and the other house I got 1.87 on that
other house since my second home so
what's your payment every month on that
well two percent on about 16 million but
20 out but about three million down over
15 million right no I owe 16 million
from 313 million 13 million times two
percent
it's about 20 grand a month
and then I got a housekeep yeah 20 grand
yeah
get a calculator out where's your phone
at 13 million yeah you're right divided
by 12. it's about 20 grand a month yeah
but then you know yeah I gotta heat the
pool yeah tax taxes are about
130 40 Grand a year or more that's still
not terrible about a percentage it's not
valued at the house it's valued at with
the ability to build and land and you
know he didn't tell what he paid to
build it yeah anyway it's um you know
all together you know it probably cost
me about whatever 40 Grand a month to
live there with housekeepers and
utilities I I lowered my Landscaping
bill I swear to God I hated my
landscaper he was gonna be [__] oh
yeah replace this we are fixed average
it is [__] I got rid of my
landscaper I replaced all the Lawns with
fake grass and I love it I gave my kid
out Putt-Putt thing and I cut out the
[__] landscaper I fired the pool
company got the guy from the hotel it
does my clearer Beach Hotel come do it
nice I've been cutting expenses
what about now what about insurance
because I heard Florida we just renewed
I only renewed it for five dollars five
million worth damage okay
um so my insurance is like 24 Grand a
Year my son just called me today on it
and then flood is that would be flood is
the maximum while you get on foot
anyways you know
and then the house is built to where if
it floods all the walls somehow I don't
know something happens where it protects
the house it's probably the lower level
only the bowling alley and he gets
destroyed got it huh that's good enough
only the bowling yeah a bunch of balls a
bunch of shoes and a [__] a couple of
lanes last time you used the bowling
alley in your house the last time the
last time was when I pulled my back out
from Bowling so it's been a while I
don't do I don't I used to Bowl as a kid
but no it's for kids so how many square
feet is the house twenty thousand in a
20 000 patio
okay so forty thousand square feet one
percent square up not heat is sure well
the garages are air conditioned here but
they don't count what percent of this 40
000 square foot place do you think you
actually use 200
200 a bid no I'm in my bedroom you know
it's pretty big but you know the bedroom
I basically live in my bedroom and my
office there's the elevated account of
square footage yeah I see the elevator a
lot I use the office to use the elevator
and then she pulls me into each and
otherwise the rest of the house is for
the kids that's crazy because for me I
just wonder like why would anyone
it was a deal baby it's my it's my like
insurance policy oh [__] goes to hell
yeah I could put on the market tomorrow
I know I can at least 28 even in this
market I only paid I only owe the bank
how much uh I said 13. I could go get 15
million bucks and if I need it out of my
house
that makes an Investments you know yeah
can you tell us the details about the
plane you bought because you bought a
new plane didn't you recently I own
Partnerships I'm a partner in about
three different planes okay I don't want
to own my own plate it's just crazy the
bills one part broke the other day was
20 grand and that was a cheap part
I mean basically I have partners and
none of us ever have any conflicts with
using them you know you want to use the
plane you call up you got a man he said
hey when he's playing go here go there
whatever and then um we all share in the
maintenance course every month we'll
share you pay whatever hours you use you
know whoever whatever whatever partner
uses x amount of hours pays the hourly
engine service based on his hours you as
soon as you're done using the pain you
got to write a check to the pilots in
the gas and any other fees and Landing
fees
and then if it breaks we all got to
split the bill yeah but I got four guys
to split the bill way when it comes to
him we're gonna get our damn plane
painted the other day it costs like 80
grand yeah because it's a special type
of paint right that has to get approved
they claim that the reason why I was
good my plane my plane the one we're
talking about is the um
foreign
Premiere okay and it's made out of comp
ound or pounds pose anyway it's not like
a middle plane I had to go somewhere
special blah blah blah blah blah for
cracks of course 80 grand paid a [__]
plane you could have done it for 20. but
yeah man I could have well if it was a
regular plane and if I was a local Yoko
but they want to go a big shot place and
all that anyway so at least it cost me
20 out of the 80 because I got four
Partners three other partners how much
is the plane we paid about
the guy that's one of my partners is
like an expert in buying [__] car you're
enjoy the auction business one plane
cost a million to have the other one
cost like a million eight the other
one's a g 100 I never use because it's
too expensive takes two pilots the
premiere only takes one pilot and it's
for long distance you know but certain
Partners use certain planes more
depending on the lifestyle but I got
that and I got the prop plane the 414
that I use now because I'm being a
cheapskate and I make my kids use that
to bounce around Florida so I can that's
only good for Florida
I saw a clip of you breaking your
private jet
no you're probably sure the prop plane
where I got on and it tilted down that
was that was that was for the that was
for the clip that was for The Tick Tock
clip right there that's my question was
for that yeah yeah could you elaborate
what was that elaborate well the guy or
something I don't know maybe now the
plane blocked right or whatever or maybe
there's a certain way you're supposed to
load a plane but when I got on a plane
the whole front went up and it was true
it happened and uh it did damage no it
didn't do a damage none no
it just tilted in the bottom of the tail
hit the ground I mean you'd think there
was something as delicate as a plane
that that would like encourage like cars
like aluminum or metal or sheet metal
whatever I mean could you just get
someone in the front of the plane too
like load an extra few people to sit in
front balance it or no we balance when
we sit in the plane normally we make our
fall [__] with the pilot up front yeah
two planes so how much would it cost you
then to make the average trip on a plane
like that
what I do a lot is I go to Fort
Lauderdale which is about 250 miles
if I take the prop plane I gotta pay for
a pilot he's about 800 bucks a day even
if he's only working two hours you gotta
pay him for a day so you got 800 bucks
in a pilot okay and then it's gonna run
me about and that plane it's gonna run
me 500 in gas to go 250 miles in the
prop Lane and 500 back in fuel so I got
a thousand bucks in fuel and I got 800
of the pilots eighteen hundred dollars
if I take the premier jet it's going to
be about 700 more for the fuel
if I take the g100 it's going to be
about 17 2 000 more because you use more
fuel than any other pilot it's
interesting the same distance between
here in La yeah
every plane is different you know but
then you got the engine hours you got to
pay for two sure but we do some dry
leasing which helps with uh the expenses
right you know we'll do like dry leasing
we have a manage it handles all that so
we were discussing before this podcast
about how you negotiate absolutely
everything in your life right from Cars
to houses to the sentence that you're
going to receive when you're 17. can you
tell me other random stuff that you've
negotiated you said you can negotiate
for anything and people Overlook that
I mean I will try to negotiate and take
advantage of anything you know I mean
all right someplace you can't you know
but like you know if I'm in the grocery
store and you know I really don't want
to invite a kid that bag of candy they
want I'll accidentally open it a little
say hey this is open can I get it for
half price
um you know or we went to the buffet or
the restaurant into Bellagio and you
know my niece is really 15 but I said
she was 10. that price that's smart
she don't eat much eats the same as a 10
year old it shouldn't go by the age it
should go by size you're a small person
and you eat light then you should be
charged by your weights
you'll pay [__] 10 times the price of
buffet I would they [__] probably
would cry at this when you walk in a
[__] Buffet
holy [__] I know some Chinese guys that
would close this shop if they thought he
was coming in there coming to the
Chinese buffet in my neighborhood
you know my son got kicked out of a
Chinese buffet once no he did it he ate
too [__] much and what did that go
like for him what happened was I put him
in charge of her Palm building when he
was like 19 he drunk out of college and
I put I said go to his apartment
building I'm not paying for your tuition
no more you're not doing [__] in college
you [__] off the first year party go
work this building Edgewood Florida and
I wasn't even living there yet I reached
a lot of buying problem buildings so he
goes to his apartment building so he's
in there he's managing the building and
every month you get all the rents you
know all the time rents come in back
then we'd have to you I don't know why
but he was doing over by hand deposits
back then we're talking 2004. all right
he was doing hand deposits on the ticket
with all the rents and stamping the
checks and all that [__] it's a lot of
time writing this [__] in the deposit
ticket step into check in the bank
deposit ready to go so what he would do
is around the corner of the building was
a Chinese buffet
and he would come in there like around
right before lunch was over maybe like
two o'clock or something like that and
then you know they they were open you
know through dinner you come in here at
two o'clock and he's a big kid you know
he can eat and uh and then he comes and
he's sitting there doing his work and he
stayed here for hours doing his work and
while he's working he keeps going back
and forth eating and the guy goes you
come for lunch you stay for dinner you
get out and he got kicked out I had to
go there oh my God I had to go there and
give you guys some money to let him come
back in because he loved the place plus
he get his work done there and he
obviously wouldn't get [__] done because
you know he had food nearby we didn't
even work that is hilarious but now
they're smart they have time limits now
they all say yeah 60 to 90 minutes yeah
this is back
2004 I'm talking that's smart
a lot of people commented about you
smoking and that was one of the most
recurring comments that I got when are
you gonna quit smoking you just brought
up smoke I will quit when I die it'll
kill me seriously I started smoking back
a day when I was 12 years old
well maybe it wasn't a package well but
it was I was smoking age 12. yeah okay
and then by I know by 16 15 15 14 I know
it's back a day I remember the little
Puerto Rican place I used to go to get
him to the bulletproof glass and the guy
would sell me a pack of Newports when I
was 14 living in Hell's Kitchen in
Manhattan I've been smoking since I was
14 and it's very addictive and uh I
can't quit if I quit I'd probably kill
people but you know I mean I I don't
think I even tried you don't think you
can but I got a clean bill of health and
I went to a Mayo Clinic with my lungs
and everything I don't think I'd quit
hell no it's a drug it's addictive it's
nicotine you know it's like you trying
to quit heroin it ain't gonna happen
if I keep trying I I bet you could I
think a lot of people just genuinely
concerned about your but my body might
go into shock and say what the [__]
going on I ain't got no nicotine me
really kill me well you could think
about that take like little nicotine
patches oh I try to add patches yeah
there's so many [__] patches on and
[__] didn't work and then you smoke why
you got the patches on you get really
[__] up I have given myself nicotine
poisoning before that's what I know well
I can feel it I can say Okay I I gotta I
gotta stop smoking for at least five
minutes yeah what's that feel like what
nicotine poisoning it makes you sick you
know you'll pretty much get sick to your
stomach you know but I mean I'm addicted
to it you know and uh what is it what
does it feel like I've never smoked a
cigarette what is this it's great what
is it what is it let me tell you after
you have a [__] meal or you get laid
you gotta have a [__] cigarette you
haven't lived until you had and then if
you have a mental and if you haven't had
a menthol you really have a limit I'm
sorry but what is it what does it feel
like what does that do like how does it
have you ever got high let's be honest
come on let's be honest all right I
don't know you're gonna be honest or not
yeah all right have you ever got high
you know it's like smoking weed I hated
it I I smoked weed maybe two to three
times a month it's not your personality
personality a person enjoyed me oh man
they enjoy it but smoking cigarettes
it's it's an addictive habit but it does
relax me it calms me down gives me
something you know I don't know it's
just part of me
and it may not be part of you it
couldn't be part of you but it's part of
me but I don't like the smell of things
but I'm just trying to think like when
I'm smoking but the feeling and The
Sensation okay so what I would
understand it is similar to caffeine
that's what I have caffeine you drink
coffee I do I love coffee well there you
go same thing you get like get that kind
of feeling it's hard to explain yeah you
get this feeling in the morning when you
wake up do you need a cup of coffee me
too I love it I wake up my wife's got a
couple right by my bed I need it it just
it gets me going it gets my brain going
the cigarette's the same thing I can't
believe I sat here this long round
cigarette I mean I can you know I go on
airplanes [__] maybe go to [__] Dubai
that took [__] 20 something hours in
those cigarettes and then what's the
feeling like after like let's say an
hour and a half two hours you have to be
ready for another one baby but how does
it come off does it just like just an
urge where it's just like it's just like
it's an urge hey I mean you have a
cigarette let me tell you if you're
drinking alcohol I don't drink but uh
people that drink sometimes only smoke I
don't know how they do it our friends
they only smoke when they drink I
friends like that lots of lots of people
my age like they don't smoke casually
but if they drink it's like they need it
hey what's up with the whole new thing
with the [__] Vape I think they say
that these are vapor I can tell you I'm
not a vapor you're a vapor no I've never
had a cigarette and I don't I don't Vape
absolutely not yeah I don't like I don't
smoke things
no I don't know it's just
I I get it it kind of makes me nervous
there's rural human beings we all have a
different lives to live you do whatever
you know fits your lifestyle I overeat
I'm trying to cut down on that because I
know it looks like him
um overeating you know eating smoking
drinking devices these are things
everybody's an individual you have a
right to do what you want but you know
some people are drug addicts some people
smoke too much pot so people smoke too
much coke so people smoke crack some
people shoot heroin it goes on and on
and on and now we got pills pills you do
I know you're a Pill Popper I don't do
drugs
pills honestly it's good you don't do
drugs you got enough problems already
and they're not going to help you I mean
you know it is what it is you know I
grew up in an environment everybody
smoked around me and I started smoking
you know a lot of it's a product in your
environment when you're young you know
that's what I tell my kids if you hang
out with losers you're going to be a
loser because you know you're part of
your environment yeah I agree yeah I got
another random question if you're
comfortable answering so you've had what
two wives three wives
I don't want to talk about too much
about where my wife is very jealous and
hates the past but anyway I'm on my
third wife
this doesn't have to be about your past
relationships I'm just curious because
you but I'm done now you've been through
relationships what if this is the only
real one the one I'm in now is really
the only one I consider real
relationship so but I'm sure through
failures you've learned a lot I mean I
didn't have a quarter of those nights
what are you gonna do
you didn't what
thank you call I didn't have a quarter
of some of those nights I had two kids I
didn't I didn't hear you okay yeah that
makes sense but like what have you
learned like what was Jack's asking for
relationship advice just generally you
gotta find somebody that matches you
it's like if my wife was a go-getter or
Money Maker it wouldn't work it wouldn't
work
I mean it just wouldn't opposites
actually do well interact okay but it's
whatever works for you you know if you
feel like you're compatible with
somebody and you're attracted to them it
works you just got to stay away from
people that are going to hurt your life
my wife brought my life to build my wife
brought my life stability she stayed at
home she took care of kids who raised
the family she did all the things I
needed to do she took care of me as a
husband
um you know I pay a price for it I pay
dearly but uh you know anyway you know
but it worked for me you know I I didn't
I if I had a career wife it wouldn't be
the same I wouldn't have the quality of
life if I had a wife that wasn't worried
so much about the quality of our life
so you know whatever fits your lifestyle
whatever your needs are you know
you might want to go by the way I said
earlier you might want to go to a mental
hospital it's fine because I'm gay I'm
not gay I forgot to clarify that
delicious whatever it makes you happy I
don't care hold on a second you don't
have time I want to tell them about the
Instagram thing listen I'm going to tell
you right now being bi is still being
gay I'm not bi no I wanna I wanna tell
them about the Instagram thing so I
posted I think three years ago we were
looking for a date for Jack in the
podcast and I posted on Instagram I said
DM Jack if you're single you want to
come on the podcast be as blind date
90 guys no it was like all guys it was
all I don't I don't even know I got a
single girl and this was it was up for
like 20 minutes we got like yeah but
what's your audience your audience
that's what I'm trying to say okay you
can it depends I mean you know what kind
of girl do you want you know
what do you want you want somebody's
educated you want somebody's a doctor
you could probably go pull a doctor if
you want there's plenty of women doctors
out there you know you want a woman's
gonna blush you around what do you want
you want a woman that's gonna cater all
your needs or baby you what do you want
you gotta find what you want I'm saying
figure out what do you like it's all
about what you like
then that somebody has to fit that piece
in that puzzle that's interesting that's
really a pretty simple advice you have
to do you're creating your life when you
get involved with somebody they have to
fit your life they have to be the right
piece for that puzzle you know
and then you'll be happy
what do you want Jack do you know what
do I want yeah I don't like as far as
characteristics in a girl yeah like well
I gotta be fit number one I insist on a
woman that's fit no that honestly
doesn't matter that much honestly the
main thing is I like girls that are
smart somebody that I can have like some
good banter with that for me is very
important I don't you don't want someone
that's smart no and that's crazy because
I wonder well it's not crazy it's just
different I'm just one enough for both
of us my wife whenever we get into a
fight she always says we can you know we
don't know what fight old couples do I
know I know you're the smart one I'm the
dumb one I'm the dumb one and then what
do you say what do you say to them say
[__] she said it all oh my God
what can I ask what you guys fight about
or like what's that what's it oh he's
stupid [__] are always other people the
only problems we got in our relationship
is other people other people other
family members or this and that is never
us it's it's always some nonsense that
has to do with somebody else that we
shouldn't even be dealing with
you know so that's why we started saying
from now on the less we know about
people are better you know just just
whatever we don't want to know is there
anything else you wanted to mention I
mean you know I've been fired from every
job I've ever had in my life
the army they were willing to keep me
but they weren't offering me a great
deal
you know and before I went to the Army
you know I hung around with a bunch of
you know in the neighborhood you can't
help it you know I lived in a bar in
Brooklyn for a while when I was like 16
and it was the typical bar role of
goombas or whatever gangsters hung out
and then they had these you know
apartments above them that's where it is
in Brooklyn so we lived in this
apartment it was just me and my sister
at the time we lived in apartment over
the bar you know you hang out in the
neighborhood you know you ever see like
the boobies uh like Good Fellas with the
kids yeah hanging out you know
so anyway long story short
I started hanging out with so many
younger guys you know not the old guys
you know and I hang around they'd get to
see me around and say Hey you know and
so I figured what the hell I ain't doing
[__] I need to make some money so I went
in there and the guy says you know guy
his name was chubby he was a you know
Italian or whatever he was like what
they call the guy in that area that ran
[__] you know Captain whatever you want
to call him and he's sitting back at a
bar and he was alone charged he'd loan
people money take bets he was a bookie
that was the guy you went to in that
area if you wanted to borrow money or
you need a better horse or whatever so
he didn't care for me for some reason
any because he knew I wasn't stupid you
know ignorant people don't like smart
people you know it's just the way it is
you make them feel stupid you know
because they are so anyway chubby goes
to me one day and he says hey you know
go pay a visit to this guy
he owes me a thousand bucks
and you see I was a degenerate Gambler
you know he'd been on horses and sports
or whatever and he owed chubby your
money and uh and he tells me where the
guy lives and everything and so I go
over there and it was a similar type
building you know shitty old vomits and
knock at the guy's door
and I walk in there and you know it was
total he had a big bottle of Cuddy Sark
I don't know if you've ever seen Cutty
Sark it's a bottle of liquor it was
commonly drunk and back then and he had
a big bottle there and he's sitting on
those stupid folding tables you ever see
those stupid old tables you put out in
front of the TV yeah sure yeah and he
had a whole black and white TV with the
[__] dogs on we're talking back in
you know 80s but the rabbit ears and
[__] and he's sitting there and he had a
big belly with a white white beaded
t-shirt on he was a slob and it looked
like a [__] wreck and he was always
drunk
so I come over there and says uh Hey
chubby sent me over here you know you
got any money for him oh you act like a
tough guy I ain't got no money and he
was you know it was just a real pain in
the ass guy and I ain't got no money but
act like a big shot tough guy listen who
are you kidding these guys are gonna
come over here and break your [__]
arm if you don't pay him somebody
here I thought I almost felt sorry
forgot because I knew that if I came
back with nothing
they were gonna hurt this guy yeah okay
and um
so I'm telling a guy I say listen you
gotta have something or somebody call
somebody call a relative give me
something to go back to this guy with
give me 500 bucks 300 bucks something
all right give me something you know you
got anything no I ain't got nothing all
I got is this beat up a whole [__]
Cutlass outside you know they ain't
started any brand in Years anyway
give me the keys
I was into cars okay I hung out with
Puerto Ricans we take cars like that
anyway I had new friends that could fix
a car and fix almost anything pretty
much so give me the keys to the [__]
car
I like cars too so I went down here I
looked at the Cutlass and I was very
familiar with cutlasses because I've
taken many of them
I borrowed many of them so
[__] things dead you know ain't been
touched in a [__] year I call my
friend Edwin up he's Puerto Rican guy
who used to hang out with and come over
here and help me please take a look at
this car maybe we can make some money on
I don't know Edwin comes over there
and
we ended up
changing the battery
I bought a used battery cost me like 20
bucks we put oil in it we put water in
it we put he may have changed the spark
plug at two or something like that Edwin
got the [__] thing started and it
wasn't that bad a shape it was just stop
running and the idiot just you know just
left it in care he ain't going nowhere
anyway
so we get the [__] thing running I
got give me the [__] title for which
he gives me the title of the car
I go to another place I know to
junkyards and you know they'll buy cars
like that I go to the car
and it was actually a decent car once we
put a [__] hose to it and got it
running
so we literally junkyard the guy says
I'll give you a grant
the guy gives me a thousand bucks in a
[__] car wow
I take the thousand bucks
I go back to Chubby I give him the
envelope a thousand bucks in it yeah 10
100 bills
and he was totally just blown away how
the [__] did you get the money I let
that be he knew I couldn't get the money
he set me up just to to lose he set me
up for failure so I give him the [__]
money and the book you get their money
out of that deadbeat
so I tell them the whole story well you
know he said he had a car I took the car
I went and bought a battery uh we put
oil in it with water we fixed it up my
friend we fixed it up we took it we sold
it to another guy he knew the guy sold
it to because they're all connected and
I got a thousand bucks there you go you
guys sit there and he just listen to my
story look to me
and he says get the hell out of here
you're not right for this business
what
he wanted me to hurt the guy oh and and
then because I went to all that trouble
I lost money I bought the [__]
battery in the water and the oil
whatever or at the water but I I ended
up losing 50 bucks or 30 bucks whatever
it was in those days to fix the [__]
car to get him his [__] money back
and he says get out of here you're not
right for this type of business
he'd rather I hurt the guy or some [__]
but he thought he he couldn't believe it
I went through all this trouble and
figured out and went through all that to
get his [__] money it was like it
didn't make sense to him holy crap
anyway he saved my life yeah so that was
my Mafia story I never never got I
always stayed away from those guys
I have him for a reason jeez that's it
cool I like that finding a silver lining
to a pretty crazy story so you never
know in the moment but looking back that
is remarkable yeah
that's it well thanks so much
for having us if you don't shake hands
you gotta worry do this and that do it
punch today all right
all right here
guys check out Lexar please right there
and by the way if you want to see videos
about real estate what I'm doing every
day go to YouTube and Mala check that
life down below in the description or go
to bedmail.com shopping consult with Ben
you got a deal you got a problem get me
on the phone let's talk about what's
working out thank you so much man thank
you guys thank you